demi lovato received the vanguard award
at the 2016 GLAAD Awards on Saturday and
ET was there for the big honor I know
you have been a longtime advocate for
the LGBT community and I love you for
that
what is this honor from GLAAD Media this
award means so much but honestly I'm
just doing what should already be done
it's just talking about accepting
yourself making it easier for people to
love who they are and hopefully helping
society you know just accept people for
who they are
Lovato's longtime buddy Nick Jonas
presented the stone-cold singer with the
award a moment she later shared on
social media made her cry but it was
Demi who brought the crowd tears of
laughter with this dig at Nick during
her acceptance speech I know that you
all love Nick Jonas
but I actually have a bigger bonitas all
jokes aside lavarro told ET just how
lucky she is to have jonas by her side
how's it gonna have your buddy Nick here
to present you with the award it's good
it's amazing and he's so supportive all
the time so you guys aren't tired of
each other yet I could never get tired
okay well we can't wait to see you guys
on tour yeah thank you